welcome back so in the last segment we
were talking about how to represent a
system that has inputs u and outputs Y
in different equivalent representation
so if you have a linear system you can
write things as a state space system of
OD es X dot equals ax plus bu y equals
CX X is the state of the system Y or
measurements you are the actuation but
what we're going to talk about now is
this transfer function this complex
valued frequency domain transfer
function G of s it tells me how u maps
to Y in terms of frequencies of inputs
and outputs so I call this the frequency
domain because this complex function
tells me if I force this thing at a
given frequency what is the output of
the system okay and so the whole idea is
going to be we're going to Laplace
transform so we're going to Laplace
transform this set of equations and then
we're going to get G of s equals some
stuff ok I'll just tell you what it is
now and then I'll derive it in a little
bit ok and this is in the absence of the
plus bu if you had a plus bu you just
have plus D here ok so first things
first I should probably tell you or
remind you what the Laplace transform is
ok so let's just take Laplace transform
the Laplace transform is really just a
generalized Fourier transform that's
valid for functions that might grow
exponentially that might not be bounded
at plus and minus infinity so it's a
generalized one-sided fourier transform
so if I have a function that blows up
I can't Fourier transform it but what I
would instead do is multiply it by a
sufficiently damped exponential and then
Fourier transform it and that's kind of
what the Laplace transform is so I have
a few other kind of video lectures on
the Laplace transform to go
more depth but here I'm just going to
summarize so if I take if I want to
Laplace transform some function of time
so today I want to Laplace transform X
of T okay so X is some variable in time
T is time then this is defined as the
integral from 0 to infinity and I'm
going to say that this is the integral
from 0 minus so it starts just before 0
like a little Epsilon before 0 and time
this is a mathematical technicality and
it's this integral of x of t e to the
minus s T DT and so you can tell right
away that because I'm integrating
through time X of T e to the minus s T
all of my T's are going to go away and
I'm going to be left just with a
function of s so this is we call this X
bar of F ok there's different notations
some people use 1/2 some people use
capital X I'm just going to say it's X
as a function of s now this is the
Laplace transform of X in time and now
it's X in terms of frequency use s okay
and so the reason I'm saying that this
is a generalized Fourier transform is
because a Fourier transform would be
something like let me just write out
what the Fourier transform is and
hopefully I don't butcher it ok if I
take the Fourier transform of X I'm
going to write it as a function of X
because it's a little more natural this
would be the integral from minus
infinity to infinity of X of X e to the
minus I Omega X DX and that would equal
s bar of Omega so this is the Fourier
transform this is the Laplace transform
and if I Fourier transform something I'm
basically multiplying that function by e
to the minus I Omega X and integrating
out DX so that gives me a function of a
particular frequency so a frequency
domain representation of F where
essentially I'm decomposing f of X into
it's different sines and cosines of all
frequencies Omega and if I added up all
those sines and cosines I could re
represent that function f of X so here
notice that if I just take if I just
take this F and I plug in I Omega I
recover something that looks a lot like
a one-sided Fourier transform so that's
all I want you two to be picturing right
now is that this thing looks a lot like
a one-sided Fourier transform and so
what this means physically I want to
give you the intuitive feeling of what a
Laplace transform means before I go into
the math this variable f is now in the
complex plane okay if I evaluated F at I
Omega so if I evaluated F at any
location I Omega this is kind of like if
I had taken the Fourier transform at
that I Omega okay so G's I Omega s here
but s can also be it can have a negative
real part or a positive real part and
what we're going to find is that if I
write my transfer function so if I say
let me let me write this out so if I say
the Laplace transform of y equals the
Laplace transform my transfer function G
of s times U of s so I'm going to put
bars on everything so it's clear that
it's Olof transform so if I say that my
output Y is my Laplace transform
transfer function times the Laplace
transform of my input will write this
down in a minute but this is essentially
what we have here is that yeah this is y
of s over u of s okay so the output Y
given some input U is this transfer
function and if I multiplied you over
at y equals G you Michael G you then the
way that I interpret this transfer
function is G of s let's say now I'm
looking at G of F is if I plugged in a
pure sine-wave if I plugged in a pure
sine-wave to this U of F that would be
like an e to the I Omega T and that
would be like evaluating my transfer
function at one of these points on the
complex on the imaginary axis if I plug
in and so let me just draw that so this
is like if the input was a pure
sine-wave okay now if i plug in for you
something that is decaying and
oscillating that would be like
evaluating G at some a minus sorry minus
a plus IB so or minus a plus I Omega and
I'll have an exponentially decaying
envelope and the system will oscillate
around and similarly over here I have an
exponentially growing envelope and my
input is growing and oscillating and so
notice that the Fourier transform would
only be able to handle these pure sines
and cosines but it's possible to
represent my transfer function with
these exponentially decaying and growing
modes also so for example in some
systems I'll have an instability and
I'll need to have some a pole or a you
know an eigenvalue in this right half
plane to represent that transfer
function behavior but we'll get to this
this later what's important now is that
the Laplace transform of a function is
is relatively simple to compute it's
related to the Fourier transform and it
gives you a function in the complex
plane okay so a couple of important
properties I want you to remember
probably the most important is that if I
take the Laplace transform of the time
derivative of X so of d DT of X and T
this is just Laplace transform of X dot
okay what is that equal so if I ask you
to compute the Laplace transform of X
dot
you should just plug it right into here
and try to work it out and see what is
let's do that let's say this is the
integral from 0 minus to infinity of DDT
of X of T e to the minus s P DT now if
you want to solve this we have lots of
tools in our Arsenal how do you solve
this kind of a this integral ok so what
we usually do is we use integration by
parts and we say well this part is U and
this part is BV and so if I want to
integrate by parts then this is integral
of UDV
is UV evaluated at the bounds of
integration so that's 0 minus infinity
minus the integral of V bu DT ok and so
we just have to figure out what so we
know what U is U is e to the minus s T
if DV is DDT of X dot then V is just X
ok and so I can write this out that
makes sense so if DV is X dot then V is
just X so this equals e to the minus s T
X evaluated at 0 minus to infinity minus
now I have V which is just X so that's X
integral from 0 to minus instead of 0 0
minus to infinity and now D U is the
derivative of this with respect to time
which is minus s e to the minus s T so I
get a minus F e to the minus s T so my
minus s pops out and I'm going to call
it plus s e to the minus s T ok we're
almost done
all right so now what what is e to the
minus infinity F for any value of s
well for any you know for infinite time
e to the minus something infinity is
zero so this is zero at infinity and if
I plug in time equals zero here what's
each of the zero that's just 1 times X
is zero is X naught so what I get is
zero that's when I plug in infinity I
get zero in this exponential minus X
naught plus s this whole integral here
is now just a Laplace transform of X so
it's s times the Laplace transform of X
ok so this is a really really really
nice property I'm going to write it down
one more time and just summarize if I
have the Laplace transform of X dot it's
equal to F times the Laplace transform
of X minus initial conditions ok really
really really nice so this is one of the
main reasons why we like thinking about
things in the Laplace transform transfer
function domain is because things like
derivatives just become polynomials
essentially in F so I go from a
differential equation to an algebraic
equation when I evaluate this in the
Laplace transform domain ok so the last
step I need to show you is essentially
let's derive this transfer function from
this so we're going to take the Laplace
transform of this star equation ok so
let's take let's take the Laplace
transform of my star equation and see
what it gets ok so first things first
let's take the Laplace transform of the
the first equation and this is really
really simple so Laplace transform of X
dot is f X bar minus x-naught ok
equals constants and matrices just pass
right through the Laplace transform
because any if I had this a times X that
it could just pop out front so I have a
times the Laplace transform of X plus B
times the Laplace transform of U and
then if I look lost transform this Y
equation I can get Laplace transform of
Y equals C times the Laplace transform
of X okay so all we need to do now is
solve for X bar here and then plug it
into here and we'll get an expression Y
as a function of U so let's do this
let's bring all of my X bars over to one
side so I'm going to have F X bar minus
ax bar and because this is a matrix a I
want to say this is the same as f times
the identity matrix so this is f times
the identity matrix minus a X bar equals
B u bar plus my initial condition okay
and I'm going to keep my initial
condition around just so you can see how
it enters into the system okay so this
is X bar equals all of this stuff and I
can solve X bar of s equals s I minus a
inverse on the left times B u bar plus
si minus a inverse X naught okay
now this si minus a inverse is a little
bit of a funny object we're going to see
pretty soon that if I if I take a simple
second order OD e this is going to be a
second order this is going to be a
fraction one over a polynomial and s
where that polynomial is the
characteristic the characteristic
equation of my matrix a so this thing
has roots if you notice this is kind of
like the eigenvalue equation this thing
is degenerate
to sing one over s - si minus a blows up
to infinity at I in values of a so si
minus a is degenerate exactly when s is
an eigenvalue of a and so this is
actually one over the characteristic
polynomial of a it's kind of interesting
for now I'm just going to assume that we
have zero initial conditions because
usually what we're doing is we're
considered with the steady state
behavior after the initial conditions of
died out so the last thing I have to do
is take this expression for X and plug
it in here for y and so I get y bar of s
equals C times si minus a inverse times
B times u bar of s and what you'll
notice here is that this whole thing is
just a function of s that's my transfer
function and what this does is it tells
me if I have a Laplace transform if I
have some input U and I can Laplace
transform it I can tell you what the
Laplace transform output is by just
multiplying these two okay so that's
really really nice remember if I had
solved this in the time domain there
would be some weird convolution integral
that tells me what Y is as a function of
U and that convolution integral is
difficult here it's really really simple
if I can Laplace transform the input I
can find the output by just multiplying
with the transfer function and then I
can Universal applause transform to get
Y of T okay so we're going to get a lot
into the physical interpretation of what
this means later so you're going to have
interpretations of G of F so if I plug
in for example a sine wave for U of T
that's I'm going to evaluate G at I
Omega and that's going to tell me what
my output sine wave looks like okay
that's one interpretation if u is an
impulse so if use the impulse response I
want to whack this thing with a hammer
and see how it responds then u bar is
just 1 that's a really nice property of
Laplace transform the Laplace transform
of a delta function is the constant one
and so essentially if I want to know the
output
- an impulsive input all I have to do is
inverse Laplace transform my transfer
function okay so I'm going to write that
down this is really important so the
impulse response I'm going to say this
is Y of T given you equal delta T is
just equal to the inverse Laplace
transform of my transfer function or set
another way my transfer function is the
Laplace transform of my impulse response
if I collect data I whack my system with
the hammer and I watch it ring through
if I can collect that data and I come up
off transform it I get an approximation
of my transfer function which is pretty
useful this is actually something that
people do for system identification okay
so where this is going we have different
representations for our system we can
represent our system as either a state
space system or a frequency domain
transfer function and they both have
different nice properties so here I can
look at I gain values and eigen vectors
and stability but we're going to find
that in the transfer function domain I
can look at properties like robustness
and sensitivity and how the system
handles different types of noise and
disturbances and this is a very
graphical intuitive way to represent
systems that complements the state space
approach so we're going to be using this
to design controllers and then tell if
they are or are not robust okay thank
you